there is a popular notion in the world
that video game based movies should
never be made their terrible it's just
all-around a bad idea which that is a
completely correct notion and movies
like this are why Silent Hill revelation
so Silent Hill revelation stars this one
chick who kinda looks like Michelle
Williams but it's actually not her she's
a little girl from Silent Hill one grown
up to the age of 17 her and her dad
played by Sean Bean they've been on the
run from the cops for a really forced
plot point you got to have the people on
the run you know otherwise the movie
might be boring as [ __ ] yeah it didn't
help she meets Jon Snow from Game of
Thrones and he's all like hey how's it
going I want to get to know ya and Sean
Bean gets kidnapped and pulled back to
Silent Hill in which case she needs to
follow because all the evil things in
Silent Hill want her in Silent Hill now
we have the second Silent Hill movie
alright so if I'm being honest the first
Silent Hill movie I actually kind of
enjoyed it as far as video game based
movies go didn't piss me off I didn't
think it was a complete piece of [ __ ] it
has some cool stuff in it ending was
terrible I thought that was just all
sorts of video game [ __ ] but you
know the rest of the movie is fine
Silent Hill revelation made me question
how I ever thought the first one was
good it's almost like I feel like I have
to go back and watch the first one to
see if it actually is good or if I was
just on crack so I'm gonna talk about
what I liked and did not like in this
movie first of all what I liked in the
movie oh alright alright what I hated in
the movie the fact that the movie is
just a [ __ ] mess when she gets to
Silent Hill you see things happening
like really evil monsters are filleting
people you see these weird little things
over here you're like oh look at that a
bunch of creepy weird [ __ ] and it's so
much more boring than it should be I've
never been so bored in the movie that's
supposed to be creepy I can only say it
like this it's almost like it was like a
wax museum I went to a wax museum once
there was a thing called the dungeon of
Horrors and you go down there and you
see just like a bunch of wax people in
these torturous positions you know and
iron maidens and other dudes getting his
head sawed off it's really gory just
walking down the aisle of this wax
museum going oh look at that that's gory
oh look at that that's bloody you're
walking from point A to point B you're
just seeing blood and gore for the sake
of blood and gore there's no rhyme or
reason to it there's no plot to it that
is Silent Hill revelation this girl has
to get from point A to point B and she's
doing that
and all the while you see these little
creepy Silent Hill ish things you're
just kind of seeing it none of it's
exciting you just it's there there were
a couple of cool things there was this
like weird spider mannequin thing with
mannequin doll heads probably from the
videogame to my everlasting shame I
never played the Silent Hill videogames
ever at all in my life I recognized I
probably should have but I just never
have so I haven't gone back and done it
it's easy to say I should go back and
play Silent Hill but really of all the
things I could do in my life for
productivity playing Silent Hill isn't
really at the top of my list it's just
not there was a Southern moment that was
cool and these things were actually in
the first Silent Hill movie there's
these weird faceless nurse things that
react to sound so they start slashing at
you with their knives as long as you're
making sound but if you just shut up and
don't do anything they'll just be like
they'll freeze with their knives and do
nothing doesn't change the fact the two
idiots kept making sound I'm like you
can just do what you're doing
quieter and these things kill these two
guys like they're bad Silent Hill guys
so you don't give a [ __ ] well one of
them is trying to kind of shoo one of
the nurses away he's like hey come on
get out of here get out of here and of
course he gets killed but he eat he was
trying to get this thing away from his
friend with all the conviction of
sweeping a raccoon off the porch with a
broom Oh get out of here get out of here
it was pretty terrible at one point the
main chick runs across this girl she's
like how'd you get her she's like we
took a wrong turn we got lost in the fog
I was like I'm more interested in her
story than yours I would have rather
seen their stories are oh you got lost
in the fog and now you're in Silent Hill
that's perfectly fine with me for a
movie like this I don't need some weird
convoluted you're the other half of a
less of [ __ ] just show me simple
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll talk about the
acting in this movie no it's not good
you have good actors in the movie Jon
Snow from Game of Thrones I know he's
good Sean Bean who is Ned Stark and Game
of Thrones he's double O six from
Goldeneye he's Boromir from Lord of the
Rings that dude has proven his word in
this movie he's just not good
I gotta think it's Natalie Portman
complex she has won an Oscar she's won
an Academy Award she's a great actress
we've all seen this we all know this she
is also the one who delivered the lines
I truly deeply love you Anakin you're
breaking my heart yeah that is real so a
[ __ ] writer and director can take a good
actor and make them terrible that is
just a reality of the world now we're
going to touch on Malcolm McDowell's in
this movie which it doesn't really
matter
Malcolm McDowell is like the samuel
l.jackson of old white people they do
can be in the biggest [ __ ] movies on
earth and in the end he will still have
works people be like hey you want a
cameo in our [ __ ] movie we'll pay you do
against a steady paycheck doing it it's
fine his career won't be hurt I hope
Sean beans career comes out of this
movie all right if I'm being honest it
didn't even look like he wanted to be
there god I think it was that contract
he signed for the first movie this movie
honestly feels like a set designer and a
special effects guy got together and
they were like hey let's make a really
cool Silent Hill movie so they just
showcased their talents by showing you
crazy creepy creatures and really bad
special effects as for the 3d in this
movie I'd love to be able to talk about
the 3d but I saw the movie in 2d because
that's what was available to me at the
movie theater I would have seen it in 3d
if I could but I just couldn't but
really I don't think it matters
I really doubt the 3d would be the thing
that brings Silent Hill revelation up to
the bracket of bearable like it would be
like alright the movie has [ __ ] riding a
terrible premise terrible direction
movies just all over the place it's a
complete and total mess but that 3d that
really did save it no I doubt it
you've seen me review some movies that I
says should have premiered on Netflix
Silent Hill revelation should have
premiered on the most miscellaneous
unknown backwoods basic cable channel at
3 a.m. on a Monday and that's also where
it should have died Silent Hill
revelation is definitely absolutely
without a question
dog [ __ ] this is one of those movies
that should be avoided at all costs if
you have like the worst job ever just
know that you shouldn't skip that job to
go watch Silent Hill revelation if your
job is to unclog toilets with your
tongue while you're doing that power
through by thinking to yourself you know
what my day could be worse least I'm not
watching what Jeremy watched so what is
the worst movie of the year for you I
don't know if Silent Hill revelation is
the worst movie of the year but it's
it's certainly a contender
whatever your worst movie of the year is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
you